hey I'm Sarah I play Max hi I'm Felix I
play Marcus hi I'm Tony I play Jenny hi
I'm Brianne and I play Georgia we're
here with BuzzFeed to find out which
Ginny and Georgia character we really
are
pick a song just think of karaoke these
are the options about damn time by lizzo
Wannabe by the Spice Girls good for you
by Olivia Rodrigo as it was by Harry
Styles Mr Brightside by The Killers and
Man I Feel Like a Woman by Shania Twain
I'm gonna go with Mr Brightside I'm
gonna look good for you oh my god Mr
Brightside wannabe Spice Girls but it's
a close tie for Man I Feel Like a Woman
same pick something to order at Joe's
blue Farm Cafe we have a grilled cheese
an iced coffee fries salad blueberry
muffin bacon egg and cheese fries easy
bacon egg and cheese oh either iced
coffee or grilled cheese which one you
always get a grilled cheese okay grilled
cheese I'll get bacon egg and cheese
choose and iconic mother-daughter Duo
from a movie or show Donna and Sophie
from Mamma Mia Lorelei and Rory from
Gilmore Girls nalini and Devi from never
have I ever Tess and Anna from Freaky
Friday Wednesday and Morticia from
Wednesday or Joe and marmie from Little
Women I love never have I ever I'm going
with Melanie and Daisy I might do Freaky
Friday very nice maybe Wednesday I think
I'm gonna do Freaky Friday as well
[Laughter]
so you can have a Freaky Friday Jenny
and Georgia episode where we switch body
don't give them ideas which town event
would you love to attend Halloween
haunted house poker night Christmas
caroling July 4th cookout book sale
24-hour dance Marathon Haunted House
Poker Night poker night
what the hell wait what is this I'm
gonna do July 4th cookout that's so
sweet so patriotic of you yeah yeah okay
now choose a Ginny and George a
character to attend the event with
Austin Ellen Abby Nora Sophie or Zion
Abby Ellen yeah Ellen all the way yeah
[Laughter]
and finally picking up to the star in a
rom-com with we got Zendaya and Robert
Patterson Winona Ryder Keanu Reeves
Florence Pew Michael B Jordan This is
Hot yeah can I choose all of them yeah
or Robert or Florence I know but it's
also a rom-com so
Michael like whoa I'm gonna go Robert
Pattinson because
why wouldn't I of course sure I've
worked with him before actually
I'm going Winona Ryder I'm going Keanu
did you guys get your results
[Music]
Georgia I got Marcus you got I got
no the other thing is I didn't see that
coming okay you go your personality
matches Max your outgoing kind and easy
going like Max you love to surround
yourself with a tight-knit group of
friends you can do anything with your
sense of humor is one of your strongest
qualities and you use it to make sure
everyone around you is happy and having
a good time I mean that does make sense
thanks you're introverted determining
Charming um someone who definitely
prefers spending a quiet night in with a
good movie or book rather than telling a
big party that's true or like Puzzles
you like Puzzles I like puzzles
like Puzzles Tony you always you always
struck me as a Paul
I'm so read it why did everyone get
their actual like Disney I'm surprised
okay your personality matches Paul your
Dependable enthusiastic and hardworking
like Paul you're the person people often
turn to and they need help your Charming
personality and drive to help others are
two of your strongest qualities when
people spend time with you they also
want to be a better person that's true
yeah
okay I somehow I'm still Georgia your
personality not just Georgia you're kind
of caring and tough like Georgia you
radiate some serious Mama Bear energy
you're someone who always puts your
loved ones first always
a little while to trust people once you
do they become your friend for life okay
I'll take it that's nice
don't forget to Catch season two of
Jenny and Georgia on Netflix
[Music]